this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
minimalists
hello simpletons welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live
a meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields milburn and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists now ryan there is a reason
if you're watching this on youtube
right now by the way we have a new
youtube channel it's i think it's the
minimalist podcast on youtube
we separated our youtube channels we
have shorter minimalism videos and we
have the podcast channel
you can subscribe to both if you like or
subscribe to neither whatever you want
to do but anyway ryan
there is a reason that i'm down on one
knee right now
today we're going to talk about getting
married well not the two of us
oh i'm sorry man well you know boy can
hope
we're going to talk about everything
that's involved in tying the not
debt expenses expectations
responsibilities
ceremonies outfits wedding guests and so
much more who's ceremony
[Laughter]
oh that's uh that's a typo i mean
jessica bishop oh okay
anyway i i figured uh we by the way we
have jessica here uh the
the budget savvy bride you can find her
website the
budget savvybride.com she's also on
instagram and twitter we'll put a link
to both of those in
the show notes jess thanks for being
here today thanks so much for having me
i've been looking forward to this for
such a long time nice too
you're the best person that we could
bring in for this because ryan and i
are the worst people that you could
bring in for this we get questions about
it
all the time right people ask us about
minimalist weddings and and
you know i about 10 years ago i said i'm
going to stop going to weddings and i've
broken that promise to myself three
times in the last decade
wow i just had a line in the sand to
draw well i really dislike
going to weddings there's something
about the formality the it's just
it's probably my ocd there's something
wrong with me it's not you it's me
and and so what i realized 10 years ago
was like hey
i don't want to keep doing i've tried it
out i don't want to keep doing things
that i
dislike and so i'm going to stop doing
this thing i dislike because i'm not
getting something out of it
myself and i felt like that it was
in fact i was maybe a negative presence
on the ceremony if i really if i felt
a disdain for it however i met my
lovely wife uh bex and both of her
siblings have gotten married
since we've met and so i've been to both
of those weddings
uh also we went to our friend colin
wright's sister's wedding randomly yeah
that's right
and happy passing through or something
yeah yeah and they invited us to go in
columbia missouri
to this wedding and we got matt's
wedding next year
i know that's my fourth exception yeah
and then i think
in fact i dislike weddings so much that
i didn't even have a wedding
for my own marriage right i i decided
that like that that wasn't
for me and and backs we decided this
together obviously
and but i realized that my situation
although we can talk about my situation
we could talk about ryan's situation we
could talk about your situation
i i realized that ours isn't necessarily
a broad recipe for everyone it may work
for some people
but we have some broader advice from
your book which i'll hold up here
for youtube the budget savvy wedding
planning planner
and organizer so um a bunch of like
worksheets and
questions that you ask people that
people actually don't think a lot about
their wedding it just sort of begins to
metastasize
and all of a sudden you're i remember
this with my my first marriage is i was
just sort of nodding my head uh-huh
yeah i'll take on that debt okay right
and throw another thousand yeah we need
to talk more about that
well let's talk a bit about about this
because first before we get into our
audience questions today
i wanted to ask you what are the most
common questions and sort of objective
objections that you get about minimalist
weddings or having simple weddings or
budget-friendly weddings i think the
thing that people
tend to um have like this fear
of judgment of other people and so
there's all these expectations right
from your family your friends your
social group
like social media only adds to it i
think
as well and so there's this like feeling
that
if they plan something small and
inexpensive or or even just affordable
for their own personal budget that they
might face
judgment or um you know have other
people think that they were cheap
that's that's the question that often
comes up in my facebook group i have a
very active facebook group of like 13
000
uh brides and grooms who are going
through this process and
and that's one thing that consistently
comes up is is this tacky is this going
to look
cheap uh i think there's a lot of
kind of fear of that judgment wow um
when it comes to planning
it's so unfortunate like you you can't
even think about you and your bride that
day you have to think about what
your family and their family and what
all your friends are going to think
about the wedding instead of focusing on
what really matters yeah it seems
uh seems like a really bad distraction i
guess
isn't that a metaphor for life that
we're often focusing on the things
that well maybe there's a better way to
put it here's something pithy for you
sean that you can tweet
is uh we we sacrifice
what we want to get what we want now
and sometimes we want the approval of
other people so we're willing to
sacrifice the
the wedding that you know me and my
spouse might
want to appease other people and by the
way we're spending money we don't have
to impress these people we may never see
again i mean there's so many people that
came to my wedding
that i have never seen since i in fact
if you show me pictures yeah there you
go
if you look at pictures from the wedding
i'm like who is that person
they crashed my wedding jess let me talk
to you about
um questions that people ask you got
this this huge facebook group of brides
and grooms
what are some of the main questions that
people begin to ask
when they are trying to be more
intentional with with their wedding
um i think really just about how to like
a framework you know for making their
decisions and it's something that i
outlined in like the first chapter of my
book
it asks a lot of questions about like
what are your intentions for planning a
wedding what are your goals
what sort of vision do you have for your
day how do you want to feel on that day
do you want to feel
overwhelmed and stressed and frazzled
because you've tried to diy everything
yourself do you want to feel
calm and present and know that
everything's taken care of
because you chose to downsize and have a
small intimate wedding that's
a bit more simple to set up and you have
that sort of
sense of calm and peace so that's
something that i really encourage
couples to do is really sit down
and take the time to discuss all of
those
things when it comes to your
expectations
your desires for the day what's the
intention of it and to really keep the
focus
on the fact that the wedding itself
is just a party the marriage
doesn't need the party um and so really
focusing more on your relationship and
keeping that at the center of everything
that you're doing i think is super
important
you just gave me a huge realization i
think maybe the reason i hate weddings
is i hate parties
that's what i was thinking dude it's the
crowd of people that you don't like
right and and um well i don't mind being
the center of attention obviously
um i have a podcast it's always i want
it to be on my terms right
and and there's something about a
wedding that doesn't
but however i think you're illustrating
a great point jess what you're saying
here is that
yes this is a party and it is a party
for
the marriage but you don't have to let
other people
dictate what that party is going to look
like you're not going to their
party right you're creating your own and
so
you you can do that however you'd like
if you want to go
if you want to do it in italy with 12
people then that's an option
and we could talk about ways that to
make that affordable and make sure you
don't go into debt for that
or if you want to have a traditional
ceremony in a southern baptist church
then
that's great too if that if that's the
route you want to take but
think of it in a way where it is your
party for your
marriage not a party for someone else
yeah i think that so many people get
caught up in
trying to please other people and
managing the expectations of their
family and friends especially when you
have family members who are contributing
financially
to the wedding fund um that kind of
gives them a little bit of license to
exert their opinion uh into the
situation i would say so if you're going
to take someone's money
yeah then then it's probably they're
going to be strings attached there's no
such thing
as a free lunch right right it's not a
donation it's a contribution but they
probably have some
expectations of things that they want to
share their input on
in exchange for those dollars yeah so
what i'm hearing you say is be careful
about who you take money from because
they're going to have influence over the
ceremony absolutely
yeah well we do have some questions here
before we get into those though where do
people
where do people often go wrong with
their wedding planning
where do they go wrong i think like
getting influenced by outside people
and playing into those expectations from
family and friends i really think that
if the two of you are really really
clear and that's why setting that
foundation i think is so important
because you kind of create
almost like a mission statement for your
wedding and you can just kind of like
refer back to that framework
throughout your planning process and say
does this decision does this expense
does this choice reflect the day that we
want to have that we
want to have um and you know
learning to set boundaries with the
people
who might be contributing financially or
you know discussing
you know the expectations of what you
are and aren't willing to
accept their uh i don't know
feedback on you know and in some cases
like it's gonna be
a difference of opinion especially when
you're dealing with like older family
members who might be more traditional
but you and your partner
are a bit more modern and a bit more you
know laid back perhaps than
what they might be used to and so i
think it's a really wonderful thing
now that couples are really making their
weddings their own they're making them
much more i don't know relaxed and
comfortable and
and not so stuffy and formal like you
were saying like
i think it's it's wonderful that there's
been a bit of
a casualization of weddings yeah yeah
i think one of the mistakes i made was
the
allowing the inertia to carry me forward
like okay
we've decided to get married and this is
my first marriage and and i
we were just like hey all right well
then you do the things you're supposed
to do
right and for me the the most common
mistake that i i see
people do is they're just not
intentional it's
it's absorbing everyone else's input and
and not being really clear on what you
wanted to look like i remember the day i
showed up you know ryan was there he was
in my wedding party and um
i signed a life insurance contract the
second time
and so the the um
at the the ceremony itself like i showed
up and i was just like
oh like i guess this is it like i didn't
really have a whole lot of input like we
didn't sit down
and use a resource like your book for
example to get really clear on
what we wanted what do we want this day
to to look like it's what our friend
chris hogan says
dreaming in high definition and
i think really i mean if you want your
dream wedding you have to get really
clear
high definition clear on what you want
the day to look like what are your
expectations more important what are
your standards
that you want to adhere to not what are
someone else's standards because
if you try to appease and please and not
that you want people to be
negatively influenced or impacted by
your wedding right
but if you try to appease all 200 people
who are going to be there you're going
to end up appeasing no one yeah
one of the biggest mistakes i can think
of i've seen people make is going
into massive amounts of debts for their
wedding and it leads back to what you're
talking about
it's they want to make sure that they
have the perfect wedding through
everyone else's
eyes they're you know thinking about
what it's going to look like on the gram
and that is like the wrong reason yeah
the wrong motivation to plan to plan
your wedding
it is my opinion that you should never
go into debt for anything other than a
mortgage that would include a wedding i
agree
and i i just think that it's uh you know
it's
a huge expense for a lot of people and
if you want to spend it you need to be
able to afford
yeah that money and so if you're going
to spend 30 grand on a wedding
what's the average wedding these days it
is around 33 34
000 which is insane to me i take a
really hard
hard stance on not taking out any sort
of debt for a wedding honestly because
another point that i bring up in that
introductory chapter to the book is
thinking about
you know beyond the wedding day
obviously the wedding day is
very special it's very important it's
one of the only days in your life where
you're going to be surrounded by all the
people who matter the most to you
it can be really meaningful and
impactful but it's easy to
you know let those outside influences
you know cause you to feel the pressure
perhaps to overspend but when you do
that
and you fail to stick to a budget that
you can realistically afford you're
basically stealing from your future
selves and all of those
goals and dreams you have for your
actual lives together
after the wedding day yeah that's
nightmares in high definition
yeah that is a high definition nightmare
my god we got some questions here let's
start with carly in
blackwood new jersey is it possible to
have a minimalist wedding that still
allows you to invite a good amount of
people for folks with large families and
such
if so what compromises need to be made
and what alternative options exist that
people may not know about
carly first off thanks for being a
patreon supporter we
certainly appreciate that so to start
with the minimalist wedding
side of the question jess tell me i mean
a minimalist wedding doesn't necessarily
mean having two people there i mean you
could especially in this time of the
world
maybe covet times that would make sense
yeah so maybe zoom weddings or a thing
now i i'm assuming that really in these
covid times
i i like to call it the pandemic pivot
couples are kind of given
the option of a few different scenarios
at this point depending on where they
are in the country
obviously um they can either
choose to just elope and get married on
their original wedding date or they can
um you know potentially do like a
backyard thing
with just their immediate family or they
can you know
um postpone to a later date
but when it comes to an actual
minimalist wedding and you're talking
about having a bigger wedding when you
are able to have more people
i think one of the best things
that you can do is to just keep
everything simple you know when it comes
to decor
that's where a lot of the cost adds up
also with with catering
is is one of the bigger expenses
catering in alcohol is typically
a big big chunk like up to 50 of your
budget in some cases and so
um that that's really the biggest
challenge is feeding and watering
everybody
uh when you have a large group but if
you can cut back in other areas
you can kind of make those allowances um
and i when it comes to decor honestly
like less is more
less is chic right yeah um there's
nothing wrong with
being very simple and i think you know
when it comes to
things like your wedding table decor
which is one of the big focus areas you
know
using the basic standard linens that
come with your you know come with your
package at your venue
white is chic it's minimal you don't
have to
do anything overly fancy you know what i
mean yeah that's the nice thing ab about
minimalism is the the bones are are the
beauty and by stripping away the
sort of superfluous decor you can get
down to something that is
that is elegant it's leonardo da vinci's
uh
line is is simplicity is elegance or
elegance is simplicity
uh when we we look at simplifying quite
often what we're talking about is
stripping away the ugly layers
yeah to get down to something that is
beautiful absolutely
i mean i'm a fan of the more the merrier
i know you are not a fan of that josh
but uh you talk about people yeah i'm
talking about people and by the way and
that's what makes the wedding go ahead
cutting the spending in other areas
allows you more room for the
the better more which for you would be
more people yeah and minimalism it has
nothing to do with the number
of anything i mean it has to do with
living intentionally being
intentional with your everyday decisions
or your grandiose decisions like
like having a wedding so yeah invite as
many people
as you feel appropriate i mean that's
that's what it comes down to
and i will ask you this though jess it
does seem that we
we do tend to overall invite too many
people as i mentioned earlier
if i look at photos from that first
wedding which i'd have to find them
digitized somewhere in the cloud but
they're out there
if i were to look at that i would just
question like who are these people and
why did i spend so much money
taking care of them feeding and watering
them yes absolutely i agree i
i look back on my wedding and i had 150
guests there
i did not get to spend intentional time
with every person there
and so at the end of the day like they
came to witness us exchange our vows but
i didn't get quality time with everyone
who was there and so
i really encourage couples to be uh like
ruthless honestly with their guest list
because at the end of the day
you know you're gonna remember the
people who are in your life
for the long haul and just depending on
what stage of life you're in like i was
25 when i got married and i was still
very much
enmeshed in my college group of friends
so we had a very big social circle and
you invite this person and then you're
obligated to invite this person because
you invited that person
and it just quickly spirals and
snowballs out of control
and so i think if you can be really
intentional about keeping the guest list
small it's
it's for your benefit yeah um and also
when you
have a smaller guest list it allows you
to spend more per guests
you know basically you're taking your
budget and you're dividing it up into
smaller chunks with every person you add
so you can make the money go farther if
you keep your guest list small as well
yeah carly i'm gonna send you a copy of
the budget savvy wedding planner and
organizer i hope it helps you out on
your journey we have another question
here from
amber in traverse city michigan so my
partner and i both have worked in the
wedding industry
he's in catering and i've done hair for
weddings before
we've both said that if we were ever
going to get married we wouldn't want a
normal wedding and we don't need to be
legally married i really like what you
guys have said about that
and for us we'd prefer to spend whatever
money
family wants to dedicate or give to us
to traveling
internationally together because it's a
passion of both of ours
but at some point we might want to have
a party for our families just to
you know have our families all meet one
day and
hang out and celebrate us how could we
incorporate minimalist practices
into this kind of celebration and is
this something that you guys have
even though you didn't have a normal or
a legal
marriage or wedding ryan if you don't
have a legal
marriage is it an illegal marriage
yeah maybe well here's the thing
i mean let's let's talk about our stance
on this real real quick because
i think this question is ultimately
about language the language that we use
so
she used a few uh words here she talked
about instead of having a wedding she
wants to have a party well we already
identified a wedding is just a party
right and so whatever
whatever vernacular you're going to use
to describe the
ceremonial event that represents
the marriage although we have already
acknowledged that
a wedding is not a marriage and you can
have
the best wedding and the worst
marriage and vice versa or they can
they can both be great or they can both
be terrible i suppose
if that that's an option there so um
let's talk about our our situation
because when she says you're not legally
married i didn't have a religious
ceremony because
i don't belong to a particular religious
tradition that would require
that and um i don't believe
i don't i don't like the government's
involvement in marriage personally
and so i'm at this weird intersection
where i don't
need and by the way the government being
involved in marriage is a relatively
new thing george washington was married
but he wasn't married by the government
right and yet he still had a marriage
right he just didn't have to go down to
the courthouse and fill out a piece of
paper
so when ryan and i use the term you know
spouse or wife or
marriage what we're using is a term that
describes the type of relationship that
we have it's a
a long-term partnership a long-term
commitment
now commitment is not birthed out of a
piece of paper we can go
sign a piece of paper right now and then
go cheat on the person the next day
and i don't mean cheat just in the
physical sense but cheating all these
we can lie to them we could steal from
them we could hide things from them
these are all different ways to sort of
cheat a relationship
and and so because of the the religious
aspect and the governmental aspect
you know i don't have a a formal piece
of paper i actually have pieces of paper
that mean a lot more to our
relationship and ryan you do as well but
yeah i mentioned a moment ago
life insurance you know to me that's far
more important than having some sort of
marriage certificate uh such a sexy
topic too
i'm insurance i know right it's like and
in fact because these things are so
unsexy
we almost never talk to them talk to our
significant other
about the most important things and so
uh i have 20-year term life insurance
ryan has the same
and that means and it's 10 times my
annual income
and so it's about 100 a month and
maybe a little bit less and and what
that means is if i die in the next 20
years
then bex and ella aren't going to be
you know out on the street you know
trying to figure out how they're going
to get their next meal or pay their rent
or or whatever and um i think that that
is to me
one sign of commitment that has nothing
to do with just signing a piece of paper
but real commitment is birthed from our
everyday actions
and and so i think that's why this is so
appealing to someone
like amber because too often what we do
is we say
i'm going to have this ceremony that
represents something and it can be
beautiful
but then we say well that was that i
guess i'm committed for life now
but real commitment doesn't look like
that it's it's more of a verb where we
have to commit
every day to that person because
otherwise we're
in that relationship out of some sort of
pious sense of obligation and no one
feels good
about being in an obligatory
relationship absolutely
and also i think deriving a sense of
your identity out of
that relationship or being married i
think
is is something that a lot of people
like can relate to
as well so well yeah i think that's
that's fascinating because
that identity the reason ryan i use that
language it's
these are sounds that we make with our
mouth we say husband wife
or whatever but like it means something
to someone else it's a shortcut to
describe
the essence of our relationship but it
doesn't describe the totality of the
relationship
uh bex and i were having this exercise
the other day when she asked me to
explain something she's like
well i need you to explain it better and
i said well try to explain why you love
me
right and and are you a words of
affirmation person
no really what i was trying to explain
to her is that you can't
you can only use language language only
goes so far yeah
and and so she could say well i love you
because you're six
two and um i
you know i i really like your hair and
i think you have a handsome face and
i like your biceps
you could you could name a dozen two
dozen three dozen things
but then say you have three dozen things
there are millions of people who fit
that 36
item criteria yeah and so it's not the
essence
i mean it's not the totality rather of
our relationship you can't describe
love with a series of checklists in just
the same way we can't describe a
marriage so what we do is we do our best
to use language
as a shortcut to communicate with other
people so if it's helpful for people
uh in this different setting i could say
my partner
i call ella my daughter she's my
stepdaughter but i call her my daughter
because i raise her
and or help raise her and and
all of that is just language to help
explain to other people
the the essence of of that thing yeah i
like the idea uh
she has here amber has of having a party
um mariah and i have actually thought
about doing something like this just
bringing the families together
um and you're all invited if you're a
patreon exactly
only the vips are invited they can all
attend from anywhere
yes that's what we'll do a zoom party
300 patrons just man
that would be yeah that would be that
would be uh
super affordable i imagine i'm surprised
at how like
meaningful and and heartfelt it is to
watch people on zoom though getting
married
i've attended a couple i've attended a
couple things
uh on zoom like a cocktail party a magic
show
just a couple things that i was it was a
it was a pretty awesome substitute for
the real thing i think i still prefer
the face-to-face interaction but
but okay so when it comes to this
minimalist party you tell me jessica if
this is the way
to approach it i would think if it was
mariah and i
uh her and i would decide first off like
what can we afford
so let's say our budget's 5 000 bucks
like and then we would start to work our
way backwards from
what that budget is is that a good place
to start yeah i think so
i i definitely think it's important to
kind of have a drop dead number of like
i don't want to spend more than this
and it should be based on what you can
realistically afford whether it's
what's in your savings account right now
or what you can save up in the time
between now and when the event is
actually going to happen um
and then yeah thinking through the big
things
like how many people are going to attend
and the venue
is going to be the biggest things you
kind of need to figure out to see if
you're going to be able to accomplish
what you want to on the budget that you
have
yeah i was uh in pasadena
and there's this like ritz carlton there
and for the ballroom for the wedding
room it's like a
it's like six figures to rent this room
out for a room
for a room yeah you just mentioned the
venue made me think about that
um yeah but you've seen some really
lavish weddings
i'm sure in in your line of work um
what are some of the most ridiculous
things that you see people spend money
on
i mean it's hard to talk about without
not
sounding like super judgmental about it
but i am kind of a little bit about just
like the over extravagance
um but i i would say the craziest things
i've
heard of people doing are things like
you know the champagne fountains or
personalized everything where like
guests get
gift bags full of stuff when they arrive
you know it's just
it's wonderful if you have the money for
that sort of thing absolutely do it like
i don't begrudge anybody who actually
has the money to spend and that's how
they choose to spend it like more power
to you
um in theory but um yeah as long as
you're doing it with intention
right not just spending money for the
sake well i'm gonna spend a million
dollars on this wedding right
right it should be on things that you
value and that are meaningful to you
and should come from a place of like
heartfelt
generosity and not like obligation kind
of like what you said before
yeah amber i really love the idea that
you are
trying to live an unconventional life
and that's why you're asking these
questions you're asking
the right questions for the right
reasons
living an unconventional life in the
face of
the status quo and the status quo is
what to go 35
000 into debt to have this wedding that
you're not going to enjoy and the people
who go there
don't want to enjoy either but the
champagne fountain
[Laughter]
and gotta have it yeah and so so i i
really like that you're asking these
questions i want to send you a copy of
our book everything that remains
it is really about these two guys me and
ryan
who started questioning the status quo
living an unconventional life which
really just means an intentional life
because intentional
especially these days is unconventional
so let's send you a copy of everything
that remains if you like our podcast
you'll like the audiobook
version of everything that remains it's
my favorite thing we've ever written
but also if you don't want the audiobook
we're happy to send you the book book
or the ebook version of everything that
remains ryan what time is it you know
what time is it it is
you know what time is it it is time for
our lightning round where we answer your
text messages
text your questions and comments to 937
two zero
two four six five four yes indeed also
if you just text a smiley face emoji to
that number
937-202-4654 we will send you every
monday
our monday morning minimal maxim via
text message these are just little pithy
ways to start your week off with a bit
of simplicity
you can also ask us questions there ryan
and i those texts literally go to both
of our phones and we
answer we respond to as many of them as
we can we even respond to some
on the podcast now jess during the
lightning round this is where ryan and i
and our guests we do our best to answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response
well tweetable responses and we put the
text to these minimal maxims in the show
notes so people can copy and share our
pithy answers on social
media if they like and now you can find
all of our minimal maxims
in one place minimalmaxims.com ryan we
got a question from april
all right what is the etiquette for the
appropriate size
and cost of wedding gifts now i do have
a pithy answer but we tend to ramble on
a little bit anyway
so my pithy answer for april's question
about etiquette and
size of wedding gifts is expectations
are an anchor of discontent
so i think if we are expecting
a certain number of of what by the way i
i got some of the worst wedding gifts
like
i think the expectations from the other
people are often really strange
i had four bread makers four i don't
register for any of those bread makers i
don't eat bread
yeah and so four people independently
decided to buy you a bread maker yes
yeah i think it's like again this is i
don't know if they were registered
anywhere so that's
that's kind of the yeah that's i
couldn't tell you right yeah um
but but what i do know is we got those
and i would never even i'm sure carrie
used it once
one of them once or something i don't
know if we returned the others i
it was so unintentional and so i think
there's something about expectations
here where we have too many expectations
for what we want but then also we have
other people have these weird
expectations like it's a wedding i guess
i should buy a bread maker apparently
that's a popular gift at least
from the sample size of one now just the
the the thought of of
wedding gifts we have something in our
minimalist rule book
um at the minimalist.com rule book it's
just a free ebook
that people can download and one of the
rules in there
has to do with gift those two rules
actually there's a gift giving
the minimalist gift gift-giving rule and
then there's the minimalist
gift getting rule which is fascinating
because
as the minimalist what we say is if you
want better gifts you have to ask
for better gifts because quite often
what we do and people think that was
minimalist we're just going to say
humbug don't give me any gifts well
that's that's inconsiderate to the
people who want to add value to your
life
and so i don't think gift giving is a
love language but i think contribution
is a love language and sometimes people
want to add value to your life by giving
you a gift so
instead of telling them no tell them
what you're saying yes
to now a gift registry is one way to do
that but what are some of the best gift
registries that you've seen what are
some of the best
gifts that people ask for well i think
especially for people who are
on the more minimalist side of things a
great option for them would be an
experience registry
or a honeymoon registry if they value
experiences over things
it's such a popular choice for couples
right now too
it's awesome register on sites like
honey fund um
is one of the more popular ones and
couples can go on and they can list
specific things that they want to do
together and it's a it's a
a combination where you can add physical
items as well if there are certain
things that you want but
you can break it down as granular as you
want to
um from like we want to do a massage on
our
honeymoon in bora bora or whatever
wherever you're going
um and wichita yeah and your guests can
just like log on and contribute to
towards those specific things um so that
like
helps i think the guests feel like
they're giving something
specific which is which is good
especially for like i think the older
folks
uh and in families and stuff like that
but it's a really great option and then
couples
get to you know take the trip that they
really want or have those experiences
that they really want rather than just
accumulating more stuff
but i do think that setting up some sort
of registry is super important to your
point
that you don't get anything that you
don't actually want
you have to give them options and let
them know what you do want so you don't
get what you don't want
yeah it's the registry thing is
interesting to me because it feels like
okay you could buy me gifts but here's a
list of the things that you can buy me
but it also makes sense for a married
couple who
they're starting out so they need items
but but to ask for like the specific
and if you don't want to get me any of
these and don't get me any gifts it just
i don't know there's something weird
there but i i do get it in the same
token well if you don't do it you'll end
up with four bread makers
right that's a good point um i had a
friend who got married i was in their
wedding
uh last year the year before but they
did like a gofundme
and i was like oh this is genius yeah
like it was just like literally like on
the
presents table it just said you know if
yeah please if you want to contribute to
our wedding go here and
maybe it was on the invitation or
something but yeah i thought that was a
good idea too i like having both options
having a gofundme which is sort of like
this this sort of blanket
you know all inclusive thing but then
there are some people
that really want to buy you one thing
specific so instead of giving you a
bread maker they can buy you a massage
which is probably actually cheaper than
the bread maker right
and i'm gonna get so much more value
from it as well and so i love the idea
of having both options yeah you got some
pithy for us ryan i do
uh my pith the answer is this gift
giving
is not a shortcut to love and i think
often
we look at uh yeah getting someone a
gift it's like this
oh here look i love you and um
that's that is not that is not love love
is is
showing up it's being there for that
person it's supporting that person
so you know maybe when you're setting
expectations for those gifts if someone
can't afford a gift just ask for their
support
that's the best way to show love yeah
the the materialistic
transaction is how we often treat love
but
but love is not transactional right it
is transcendent
and that's why we talk about language
and we talk about gift-giving and all
these things but love is
is so much more than that now you can
show that you want to add value to
someone's life
with a gift but in order to do that you
have to be very intentional with a gift
otherwise it does the opposite it's
actually being inconsiderate
if you get me a bread maker and you know
i don't eat bread or you didn't even
happen to ask the question yeah yeah
well and to the
point of or of the question about
etiquette i think
a lot of people in certain areas of the
country especially like i know i have
family on
long island in new york and it's very
much like oh we spent x
amount of dollars per head for every
guest there so
people want to know that so they know
how to give like an appropriately valued
gift
and i would argue that like gift gifting
and the spirit of being generous and
heartfelt with your gifts
shouldn't be like a tit-for-tat like
transaction
um it should come from a place of like
heartfelt generosity and you want to
give them something to add value to
their life and it shouldn't necessarily
have to
stick to a certain dollar amount
especially if it's outside of your
budget
yeah it's like oh okay they spent a
hundred dollars on each person so i need
to give a gift that's a hundred dollars
or
more i mean yeah that yeah i totally
agree that's probably like that though
the expectation in some areas of the
country it's like a very
like societal pressure kind of thing wow
for sure
man it makes me so happy that mariah and
i are not planning a wedding
that's important so so last thing to
talk about here is
being on the same page and and sometimes
you're not going to be on the same page
you're going to have
different beliefs from from your
significant other in fact that's quite
often what makes a
relationship uh passionate right is
having different interests or different
beliefs
you want to make sure you have the same
values and we talk about this
we have a values worksheet the
minimalists.com values it's free you can
download it but
if you have the same values you're still
going to have different beliefs which
means from time to time
or maybe a lot of the time you're going
to be on different pages
and then the key is to find the page in
which you can meet in the middle we call
that compromise
now you don't want to sacrifice your
values but you can compromise those
beliefs to try to meet someone
on the same page all right before we get
into our listener tips and our added
value segment today i'm going to do a
little reading for you today on the
added value segment
it looks like we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week like
how do you plan a debt-free wedding what
are the best ways to scale
down a wedding also we're gonna talk
about wedding stress we're gonna talk
about diy
weddings we're gonna talk about family
expectations and streamlining expenses
and simple ceremonies and and outfits
that's why ryan's wearing a tuxedo right
now my tuxedo shirt
we're gonna talk about uh different gift
ideas other than bread makers
and we're gonna talk about the illusion
that everything can be
perfect plus we've got a million more
questions for the budget savvy bride
jess uh if you wanna hear all that check
out our maximal episode
on the minimalist private podcast it's a
completely separate podcast it's just
two bucks
and it's the most honest way for the
minimalist to earn an income because
we don't believe in advertisements head
on over to theminimalists.com
support and get your personal link so
that our maximal episodes
play in your favorite podcast app it's a
separate podcast it'll show up right
there
in that podcast app right next to the
minimalist podcast they're just longer
episodes and
really this is where we let our hair
down we get to talk about things that we
wouldn't usually
talk about in public ryan what else you
got for us this week here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners
check them out hey there this is anna
from minnesota and i have a tip for
anyone getting married that
doesn't need a bunch of household gifts
i'm currently planning my own wedding
and was kind of dreading the registry
process
until i found out about a website called
honey fund this website allows couples
to register for honeymoon expenses such
as hotels flights and all the fun stuff
like wine or beer tours or parasailing
you can customize it however you'd like
and your loved ones can pay for parts of
your honeymoon right on the site through
paypal account
it's a very easy process for both the
couple and the guests and it's taken a
lot of stress out of our own wedding
planning process
hey josh and ryan this is helen from old
town maine
i'm one of those people that absolutely
hates putting something in the garbage
that still has life in it
just because no one has a need for it
old torn up clothes included
this month i'm going to the a developing
country on a christian medical mission
trip
what i've been doing is i've been taking
some old jeans that i no longer
use with really tattered bottoms cutting
them to pre-length and using the denim
to make hackies act
i then hem the capris so they don't look
tattered i'm planning to bring the hacky
facts down with me as a group game that
will be a gift for some of the kiddos we
help out
and i can wear the capris while i'm down
there and then leave them for someone
who needs them after i'm done using them
this way perfectly good jeans are not
ending up in a landfill
i'm getting rid of excess stuff someone
gets a pair of capris
and a whole bunch of kids that don't
have money for or access to toys
will get um hacky sacks to play with
it's a win all around
all right y'all let's say thanks again
to jessica bishop for joining us today
thank you check out being here check out
her book it is called
the budget savvy wedding planner and
organizer we'll put a link to it in the
show notes you can also
find her on her website the budget
savvybride.com
also instagram twitter and her facebook
group as well we'll put a link to all of
that
in the show notes um for added value
this week
um ryan actually the last one i think
was last week or two weeks ago i
recommended american affairs to you
yes because we're so bogged down with
news now
like we don't know what's important with
headlines and click bait well there's no
clickbait here in fact
um this is a have you heard of this
it's a quarterly journal oh let's look
at this
look at this ryan it's about policy
specifically oh whoa
uh did did you do this or did a
publisher do that dave did it
so we have the if you're watching this
on youtube love people use things
bookmark and uh i think we'll probably
do like we'll do these for anyone who
pre-orders that book makes me feel like
uh
american psycho when they're comparing
business cards
at the stock boom
yeah so the uh this book is or in a book
it's a quarterly journal called american
affairs
i just want i forgot to bring it in last
time but um you can't have this because
bex is still reading it
but lame thanks bex yeah so um
basically in terms of the news i think
too often
we get caught up in this 24-hour news
cycle but these are long-form essays by
people all over the political spectrum
and what i what i love about that is
it's a deep dive and it challenges my
own thoughts my own opinions my own
beliefs
in ways that either help me solidify my
point of view it helped me expand on my
point of view or sometimes changes my
mind about certain things
you know you said the 24-hour news cycle
but like i'll get caught
in the five-minute news cycle man
twitter news yeah it's crazy
it's uh yeah it's yeah it's very
distracting sometimes so speaking of
that i've you know i've been reading a
lot less online a lot more
in print and on on my kindle and
you and i often talk ryan about
sometimes we need to remove the things
that add value to our life
before we can decide whether or not we
want to bring them back in
so in our minimalist rule book one of
the rules in there is called the no junk
rule
and what we do is we say everything that
you own can be can fit into one of three
piles it's either
a necessary or essential item a truly
essential item
non-essential or junk well the problem
is that we all have the pretty much the
same essential needs
food shelter basic clothing we all have
those
those needs champagne fountains
and then we have the the non-essentials
which are the things that truly add
value to our life
but you know we could probably get by
without them uh i don't necessarily need
a couch or a dining table i would live
without them
but they augment or enhance my
experience of life and so that's a
non-essential and then the third
category is what most of us own
most of is junk and we pretend these
items often masquerade as
as things that add value to our lives
because third and fourth bread maker
[Laughter]
we talk about junk the first one was
junk for me and that's actually a good
lesson though right because
sometimes the thing that's junk for me
like someone else could use that bread
maker every day and get immense
value from it now there are other times
though where i will temporarily deprive
myself
i will get rid of even the
non-essentials the things that add value
to my life
for a temporary period of time and this
is a really good example i used to
subscribe to the paris review
which is a quarterly journal that
has a lot of fiction and poetry and
there's also
a few literary interviews and stuff i
like doing this kind of long form
reading um because it's some of the most
talented writers and it's almost like
getting
it's like going to a sample a place that
just has like sample platters
it's like a topless restaurant there we
go but for literature
and so you get a little bit of that
analogy thank you and so like
you get some of these you know
phenomenal writers whether it's mary
carr
or matt summell or just different people
who who
write really well and you get these
little snippets and if you want to
explore them
further you can buy entire books from
them or whatever separately
but i unsubscribed from the paris review
is because i was reducing my
subscriptions a few years ago because we
automatically subscribe to way too many
things and before we know it we have
two hundred dollars a month worth of
subscriptions to netflix and hulu and
disney plus and quibby and
wigwam and cso yeah it didn't
quivey went out of business didn't they
they've got billboards all over the
place i know i just read an article
though about how
and it doesn't matter no no i think
they're they're still around okay and
they're still giving it a shot um anyway
i
got rid of the paris review and i i said
you know what i want to
i think i really miss this and it's been
a couple years now
and my experience each morning bex and i
will turn on our
our playlist and we'll just like sit
down and read for 15 to 30 minutes
and drink some coffee and i missed
reading
these sort of long form pieces whether
it's fiction or non-fiction anyway in
the latest
issue it's issue 233. we'll put a link
to it in the show notes
there is this piece in here from
what is her name sarah sarah mengusso
and it is called perfection and i don't
really know how to describe it i'm just
going to read a few lines from it
but it's really like this this mirror
in a way i i kind of see myself i see my
flaws in this person
i don't know if this is a memoir or if
it's like flash fiction or if it's
poetry or if it's all of the above it's
sort of
auto by autobiography it's all of these
things
but it's almost like she wrote the story
one minimal maxim
at a time so each line is so very well
considered that's why it almost feels
like
like poetry anyway i was talking to sean
we were hanging out this weekend
and uh he has a family member who is
uh struggling with uh trying to get
everything perfect
as we all do i'm a perfectionist right
and clearly this author is a
perfectionist
as well and it can lead to that as well
perfectionism and
i think that doesn't that in terms of
weddings that really
um that stifles and makes the whole
process not enjoyable
when we are just trying to make
everything perfect how many brides do
you know and brides mothers do you know
that are stressed out of their minds
while they're planning a wedding
so many yeah i think there's this this
illusion that you can achieve
some sort of perfection on your wedding
day and uh it just adds
a lot of pressure yeah it's unfortunate
when people are like when this is
perfect
that's when i can be happy yeah you can
just be happy now yeah enjoy the process
right yeah and you're not going to get
to perfect but you can work toward a
more ideal version
that's called improvement or growth you
know responsible growth
anyway here's a few lines from this at
the 25th reunion a
presentament of the grave now all the
girls from your high school
class have borne the last of their
children it was just a standalone
paragraph
and it just made me think about like
this this person is obviously getting
older as we are getting older as we are
all
getting older it doesn't work the
opposite way no one is immune yes
i i can't believe we've been doing this
for like going on 10 years now i know
it's crazy it'll be 10 years in a couple
months yeah yeah
it is well uh all right here's another
line for you true happiness is
relinquish
is relinquishing one's sense of
entitlement to it
that is that's good that is good so i
kind of i think we feel entitled to
happiness
yeah but even in the constitution that
uh or declaration we don't talk about
the
the entitlement to happiness we talk
about the pursuit of happiness right
you just talked about enjoying the
process that's really what the pursuit
of happiness is
is is the process and and so true
happiness
is relinquishing one's sense of
entitlement to it here's a slightly
longer passage
a passenger jet dives into the ocean and
bobs up to float on its side
through the little window i can see the
calm passengers chatting and drinking
from their little cups
parents holding their children as i
watch the planes sink i wonder
at their cur i wonder at their courage
and calm after i wake up i realize they
may not they may not know yet
that they've crashed the passengers
classmates ex-friends ex-lovers
should all be dead to me but i watch
their lives continue as i lurk on their
facebook pages
studying photos of them sitting in
restaurants toasting in the very best of
times
going bald and doughy holding their wine
glasses up toward the lens
in their world they are still alive in
the beginning i eagerly offered
i eagerly offered myself up for
punishment
then i got older and pretended i'd been
in control all along
directing those who had hurt me telling
them what to do
there isn't enough money in the world
for me to do that i think
but then i remember what i've already
done for free
that's so true like we are our own
punishers yeah um
the the the baggage that we are carrying
we don't realize we picked it up
and what i love about this is there are
many people that we
continue to stick around our lives that
are sort of i don't mean this in a
pejorative way neither did the author i
don't think but they're they're dead to
us now
the people i mentioned from my wedding
from um
almost 20 years ago um
they're dead to me not in a literal
sense but
i don't keep up with them if they scroll
my facebook feed
the once a quarter i get on there all of
a sudden they're sort of reincarnated
for a moment
but then they're gone again and i think
we give too much important
to too much importance to that and what
happens is we forsake the people closest
to us
because we're we're constantly looking
in that rear view instead of
looking forward so many desires can now
be satisfied quickly that it seems all
desires should be satisfied quickly
capitalism wants you to consume more and
faster
but the speed at which thought develops
or at which
trust develops has not changed i
reassure myself
but what if it has so i'm going to leave
the rest of
that for you all to read if you want to
check it out it's the newest issue of
the paris review
issue 233 we'll put a link to the paris
review in the show notes
real quick for right here right now one
thing that's going on in the life
of the minimalist you may not know this
but all three of our current books
minimalism everything that remains and
essential are
available as audiobooks so our longest
one which is essential is about six
hours long our shortest one which is
minimalism
is i don't know maybe two and a half
hours long and then
everything that remains is somewhere in
between four hours or so probably
and you can check those out on audible
or itunes or wherever you get audio
books people often ask us
what order do you recommend reading them
in because read them in any order and
yes you could if you wanted to
but the most ideal order is you start
with everything that remains then read
minimalism then read essential it's the
why
the what and the how why to what to how
to everything that remains minimalism
essential if you want to check those
books out they're available as
audiobooks
we'll put a link to those in the show
notes you can follow the minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram
at the minimalist follow jessica at on
instagram she's at
budget savvy bride and on twitter she's
at savvybride you can follow her there
come see one of our live podcast shows
visit
the minimalists.com tour to find a city
near you if you have a question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast
email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com the
minimalist podcast i think that's right
or slash the minimalist we have two
youtube channels now check them both out
if you'd like
uh you can comment on this episode oh i
already said that youtube.com and if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our email list
over at the minimalists.com you'll also
receive our simple sunday
emails whenever we send those and if you
leave here today with just one message
we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it